>> Jesse: THAT WAS
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP AT THE
WHITE HOUSE WITH
ATTORNEY GENERAL WILLIAM BARR
AND COMMERCE SECRETARY
WILBUR ROSS TALKING ABOUT THE
ISSUING OF A NEW EXECUTIVE ORDER
BASICALLY ORDERING FEDERAL
DEPARTMENTS AND AGENCIES TO
HANOVER RELEVANT DATA THAT THEY
VISIT US, PIECEMEAL OR NOT OVER
WHO IS IN THE COUNTRY ILLEGALLY
OR LEGALLY, CITIZEN OR
NONCITIZEN AND THEY COULD COME
FROM ANYWHERE.
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES, USDA,
SOCIAL SECURITY, TREASURY.
IT ALL GOES TO THE COMMERCE
DEPARTMENT WHICH RUNS THE CENSUS
AND NOW THEY WILL HAVE A MORE
ACCURATE COUNT OF WHO IS IN THE
COUNTRY LEGALLY.
>> Greg: USING PREVIOUSLY
AVAILABLE DATABASES, ABOUT 90%
ACCURATE.
IT'S ALMOST EXACTLY WHAT SCOTT
ADAMS SAID.
THIS GOES TO THE BIGGER QUESTIO
QUESTION.
DEMOCRATS HAVE TO UNDERSTAND
THIS.
IT'S AMERICA'S DECISION ABOUT
OUR BORDERS AND OUR CITIZENSHIP,
NOT THE REST OF THE WORLD.
IF YOU IGNORE THAT, YOU'RE GOING
TO END UP WITH BREXIT BECAUSE
BREXIT HAPPENED WHEN MILLIONS OF
BRITISH CITIZENS SAW GERMANY'S
DECISION IMPACT THEIR FUTURE
IMMIGRATION.
THAT CAUSED THE FRACTURE, CAUSE
THEM TO LEAVE THE E.U. BECAUSE
THEY SAID GERMANY IS GOING TO
LET ALL THESE REFUGEES IN.
THEY'RE GOING TO END UP IN
ENGLAND.
GOVERNMENT SEIZES TO ENFORCE
THEIR BORDERS IN AMERICA WILL
END UP LIKE THE E.U. AND STATES
WILL HAVE TO CREATE THEIR OWN
LONG-TERM SOLUTIONS TO IMPACT
SECURITY.
ARE WE GOING TO DIVORCE?
ARE WE GOING TO WORK TOGETHER?
I WOULD RATHER SEE THE COUNTRY
WERE TOGETHER THAN DIVORCE OVER
THIS.
>> Jesse: THE PRESIDENT SAID
HE NEEDS THE RELEVANT
INFORMATION TO MAKE INFORMED
PUBLIC POLICY WITH REGARDS TO
IMMIGRATION, HEALTH CARE, VOTING
RIGHTS ACT, AND ALSO TO DEAL
WITH CONGRESSIONAL APPORTIONMENT
WHICH IS GOING TO BE CHALLENGED.
>> Dana: AND THINGS LIKE
INFRASTRUCTURE.
I MENTIONED USDA BECAUSE THAT'S
WHERE, IF YOU'RE ON FOOD STAMPS,
FOR EXAMPLE, OR YOU ARE A
FARMWORKER, THINGS LIKE THAT.
FROM A LEGAL ISSUE, THE COMMERCE
DEPARTMENT DID NOT SET THIS UP
WHILE INITIALLY THAT'S WHAT LED
TO THIS LEGAL JAM THEY WERE IN
AND WHAT BILL BARR, THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL SAID, THE
IMPEDIMENT TO ADDING THE
QUESTION WAS A LOGISTICAL ONE.
IT'S NOT A LEGAL ONE.
HE STILL MAINTAINS IT WOULD BE
LEGAL TO PUT IT ON THERE BUT
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO
DO THAT IN TIME IN ORDER TO DO
THE CENSUS SO THEY HAD TO TAKE
ANOTHER ROUTE.
FROM A POLITICAL STANDPOINT, I
THINK PRESIDENT TRUMP WOULD BE
IN A POSITION TO SAY IT'S A
WIN-WIN FOR ME.
HE WOULD SAY FOR AMERICA.
HE HAS RAISED THE ISSUE, THE
QUESTION OF VISITED COMMON SENSE
TO WANT TO KNOW HOW MANY
CITIZENS ARE IN THE COUNTRY?
I'M TRYING TO FIGHT FOR IT AND
FIND A WAY TO DO IT AND THE
DEMOCRATS WANT TO BLOCK ME IN
THE COURTS WANT TO BLOCK ME BUT
I FOUND ANOTHER WAY THAT I'M
DOING EVERYTHING HE CAN SO HE
FIGURES OUT HOW TO TALK ABOUT ON
THE TRAIL.
>> Jesse: HE SAID THE
DEMOCRATS ARE TRYING TO CONCEAL
THE NUMBER OF NONCITIZENS IN THE
COUNTRY.
>> Juan: HE WENT AFTER THE
COURTS.
HE WENT AFTER THE LEFT-WING.
HE SAID THEY ARE TRYING TO STOP
THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE IN
MINNESOTA, ANOTHER TOTAL LIE BUT
OKAY.
>> Jesse: THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT'S HAPPENING IN MINNESOTA.
>> Juan: NO IT'S NOT.
IT'S RIDICULOUS.
>> Jesse: IT'S BEEN ALL OVER
THE NEWS ALL DAY.
>> Juan: ALL IT IS IS A
CITY COUNCIL IN ONE CITY THAT
SAID YOU DON'T HAVE TO DO IT AT
THE START OF THE CITY COUNCIL
MEETING.
NO ONE IS BANNING THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE.
I GET THE IDEA THAT PEOPLE ARE
FEARMONGERING AND THAT'S WITH
THIS PRESIDENT IS DOING.
HILLARY CLINTON SAID TODAY THIS
IS WEAPONIZING FEAR AND BIGOTRY
AND I COULDN'T AGREE MORE.
>> Greg: QUOTING HILLARY IS
NOT A GOOD THING.
>> Juan: I THINK SHE'S RIGHT.
I TELL YOU SOMETHING, THE
SUPREME COURT OF THE
UNITED STATES SAID NO SO HE HAS
FOUND -- YES, THEY DID.
>> Jesse: THE RATIONALE FOR
INCLUDING IT WAS NOT UP TO
SNUFF.
>> Juan: IF IT WAS JUST A
MATTER OF EXECUTIVE ORDER HE
WOULD'VE DONE IT BEFORE.
MADE THEIR ARGUMENT TO THE
SUPREME COURT AND THEY SAID NO.
>> Jesse: THEY DID NOT SAY NO.
THEY WERE GOING TO READDRESS IT.
THEY DON'T HAVE TIME.
>> Juan: THEY DON'T HAVE TIME
BECAUSE THEY LOST IN THE
SUPREME COURT AND NOW IN FACT
THE SENSES IS THE RESPONSIBILITY
OF THE CONGRESS AND HE IS GOING
AROUND THE SUPREME COURT,
AROUND --
>> Jesse: NO, IT'S THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE COMMERCE
DEPARTMENT, JUAN.
WHY IS IT SCARY TO ASK THE
QUESTION?
>> Juan: IT INTIMIDATES PEOPLE
WHO SHOULD BE DISSIPATING IN THE
CENSUS.
>> Jesse: YOU KNOW WHAT OTHER
QUESTIONS THEY ASK.
THEY ASK IF YOU ARE IN A
SAME-SEX MARRIAGE.
THEY ASK IF YOU WERE BORN IN
PUERTO RICO.
AGE, RACE, HOW YOU COMMUTE TO
WORK, HOW MUCH USE THE INTERNET.
ALL THOSE QUESTIONS ARE SCARY?
>> Emily: IT IS MANUFACTURED
OUTRAGE AND IT IS SO
TRANSPARENT.
I DISAGREE WITH THE
RESPECTFULLY, JUAN.
TO YOUR POINTS, DANA, IT'S
TELLING THAT A, JUSTICE THOMAS'
COMMENT SAID THAT IN HIS
SEPARATE OPINION HE BASICALLY
SAID THIS IS THE COURT THAT IS
DOUBTING THE SINCERITY OF WHAT
IS OTHERWISE AN ADEQUATE
RATIONALE.
SINCE WHEN DO WE INVALIDATE
AGENCY DECISIONS BASED ON THAT?
>> >> PELOSI CALLING FOR VOTEST
>> >> PELOSI CALLING FOR VOTESO
HOLD THEM IN CRIMINAL CONTEMPT,
AG BARR.
IT'S A UTILIZATION OF RESOURCES
AVAILABLE THAT I DON'T AGREE WE
SHOULD REMAIN IN THESE
INFLEXIBLE BOXES TO THE LEFT
KEEPS TRYING TO SHOVE THE
ADMINISTRATION INTO.
FINAL POINT.
IT'S INTERESTING THAT MANY
COUNTRIES HAVE THIS QUESTION.
THE U.N. RECOMMENDS IT AS
PRACTICE ACTUALLY.
IF, FOR SOME REASON, WHEN WE
BRING IT UP IN A WAVE OF CHANGES
THAT WE OFTEN DO, IT'S
CONSIDERED DRACONIAN.
>> Juan: I WANT TO RESPOND
THAT IN FACT WHAT WE KNOW IS
REPUBLICANS, A DONOR CAME UP
WITH THIS IDEA AS A WAY TO
DEPRESSED NONWHITES IN THE
COUNTRY IN TERMS COUNTING THEM
FOR PURPOSES --
>> Jesse: THE EVENT DOING THIS
SINCE THE 1820s.
>> Juan: I'M TELLING YOU THIS
WAS PART OF THE RATIONALE BEING
EMPLOYED BY THE DRUG
ADMINISTRATION.
>> Greg: HOW DO YOU KNOW THAT?
>> Dana: THAT IS WHAT HAPPENS.
>> Juan: THAT IS WHAT HAPPENED
HAPPENED.
THIS WEEKEND WITH THE PRESIDENT
IS NOW PROPOSING IS WERE GOING
TO HAVE IMMIGRANT RAIDS THIS
WEEKEND.
>> Jesse: NO, NO, HE'S NOT.
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
>> Juan: YOU GUYS.
>> Jesse: NOT LEGAL.
>> Juan: PEOPLE HAVE LIVED
HERE TEN YEARS, 20 YEARS, YOU
THINK IT'S OKAY TO HAVE PEOPLE
KNOCKING DOWN THEIR DOORS?
>> Jesse: THEY ARE TARGETED
RAIDS.
PEOPLE HAVE COMMITTED CRIMES.
YOU'RE OKAY WITH NOT KNOWING
ANYTHING ABOUT WHO IS IN THE
COUNTRY.
>> Dana: CAN I ADD ONE THING.
>> Jesse: IF IT'S NOT A
SECRET, HOW MANY ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS IN THE COUNTRY?
YOU HAVE NO IDEA.
>> Dana: THE CENSUS IS DONE
EVERY TEN YEARS BUT ON THE
AMERICAN COMMUNITY SURVEY, IT
DOES ASK ABOUT CITIZENSHIP.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY WERE
HAVING THIS FIGHT.
>> Jesse: IF YOU ASK PEOPLE,
IT CAN DEPRESS THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE IN CONGRESSIONAL
DISTRICTS RUN BY DEMOCRATS.
A LOT OF DEMOCRATS REPRESENT
DISTRICTS THAT HAVE A HIGH
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT POPULATION.
NOT ALL OF THEM BUT SOME AND
THEY ARE WORRIED ABOUT THE
DECREASE IN POWER IN THE
CONGRESS AND A DECREASE IN
RESOURCES.
>> Juan: COUNT THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE.
>> Jesse: AND NONCITIZEN.
>> Greg: YOU ARE COUNTING THE
PEOPLE.
A NONCITIZEN IS ALSO AN
INDIVIDUAL.
>> Juan: YOU CAN PUT THE --
>> Greg: SO NO GENDER?
NO GENDER EITHER?
WE ARE COUNTING THE PEOPLE.
THERE ARE CATEGORIES WITHIN THE
PEOPLE, THOUSANDS OF CATEGORIES.
YOU CAN COUNT THE PEOPLE AND
THEN ASKED THEM IF THEY ARE
CITIZENS OR NOT.
THEY DON'T INTERSECT.
>> Jesse: JUAN.
THEY ASK IF YOU'RE WHITE, IF
YOU'RE BLACK.
THEY ASK IF YOU WERE BORN IN
PUERTO RICO.
THEY ASK IF YOU ARE A RUSSIAN.
>> Greg: BUT CAN'T ASK IF YOU
ARE A CITIZEN.
>> Juan: HERE IS THE
SITUATION.
PEOPLE WHO ARE HERE ILLEGALLY
FEAR THAT THEY WOULD BE -- NOT
ONLY WITH THE DOOR BE BUSTED
DOWN BUT THEY WOULD BE TAKEN
AWAY, PUT IN JAIL OR THROWN --
IT'S A THREAT TO THEM AND THESE
PEOPLE ARE OUR NEIGHBORS.
>> Greg: IT HAS NOTHING TO DO
WITH ARE.
THEY'RE WALKING AROUND IN BROAD
DAYLIGHT.
NUMBER TWO, I THOUGHT THEY FLED
THESE VIOLENT COUNTRIES IN
CENTRAL AMERICA.
I DON'T THINK THEY ARE AFRAID OF
A QUESTIONNAIRE.
WHEN VIOLENCE IN THEIR HOME
COUNTRIES.
>> ALSO --
SPEAK I HAVE TO GO TO DRIVER'S
LICENSE.
>> THE GOVERNMENT DOES NOT MAKE
DECISIONS BASED ON WHETHER OR
NOT SOMEONE MIGHT BE SCARED.
>> OF COURSE NOT.
THAT'S JUST NOT HOW THE
GOVERNMENT OPERATES.
>> HOW ABOUT THE GOVERNMENT
SHOULD MAKE THE DECISION BASED
ON OUR CONSTITUTION INSTEAD OF
HAVING THE QUESTION.
WHY IS OBAMA DOING THINGS HE
MIGHT NOW LOOK AT YOU, JESSE,
YOU HAVE TOTALLY TURNED.
WE LOVE EXECUTIVE ACTION.
>> THEY CAN SUE AND THEY CAN BE
HELD UP IN COURT.
>> YOU GET YOUR GUY BILL BARR
BACK, HAVE THEM SAY WE'RE GOING
TO GO THROUGH THE LEGAL ACTION.
IT'S UNCONSTITUTIONAL!
YOU CAN'T GO AROUND THE CONGRESS
AND THE COURT.
>> IF YOU ARE THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES, YOU OPERATE
THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH ALL OF
THESE DEPARTMENTS AND THESE
AGENCIES ARE UNDER THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH.
YOU CAN'T CALL DHS AND SAY,
SECRETARY, CAN YOU SEND OVER THE
DATA THAT YOU HAVE?
YOU'RE SAYING THAT'S
UNCONSTITUTIONAL GIVE MIKE SPEAK
FINE.
WHAT I SAID TO YOU WAS --
>> THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT HE'S
DOING.
>> THE CONSTITUTION SAYS THE
CENSUSES UNDER THE AUTHORITY OF
THE CONGRESS.
WHAT YOU SEE FROM A COMMERCE
DEPARTMENT.
IF THE COMMERCE DEPARTMENT
ACTUALLY OPERATES.
IT'S THE CONGRESS THAT HAS OF
THIS AUTHORITY.
THE PRESIDENT IS NOW GOING
AROUND THE COURTS, AROUND THE
CONGRESS.
>> NO HE'S NOT.
>> TO FIRE UP HIS POLITICAL BASE
WITH THIS KIND OF BIGOTRY.
>> HE'S ACTUALLY DOING SOMETHING
IN THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH, WHICH
HE RUNS.
>> IT SOMETHING THAT HE PROMISED
AND IS WORKING ON IT HE'S KIND
OF LAID IT OUT PRETTY CLEAR,
IT'S A SIMPLE QUESTION AND IT'S
A QUESTION THAT SOMEHOW -- HOW
WAS THAT ANY WORSE THAN ASKING
YOUR GENDER, RIGHT?
THAT COULD BE SCARY.
>> OR YOUR SEXUAL ORIENTATION.
>> OR YOUR RACE, FOR EXAMPLE.
I GUESS THAT'S RACIST.
>> THAT'S IN THE CONSTITUTION.
>> L '5 IS A STRICT